ich freue mich auf Cookies
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es endlich mal wieder seit
langem Cookies und zwar keine
langweiligen Cookies Kekse sondern
Blaubeer Cookies mit Streuseln so ist
zumindest die Theorie ob es in der
Praxis später funktioniert und schmeckt
sehen wir dann einfach also ich habe mir
jetzt gedacht ich werde aus Blaubeeren
so eine Art blaubeerkonfitüre zubereiten
dann noch Streusel dazu dann einen basic
Cookie Teig und dann wird es schon
irgendwie funktionieren ich zeige euch
mal kurz die Zutaten ich verwende dafür
200 Gramm Blaubeeren aus dem
Tiefkühlfach 50 g Zucker etwas
Zitronensaft und für die Streusel 50 g
kalte Butter 50g Zucker einen halben
Teelöffel Zimt dann Viertel Teelöffel
Salz und 100 g Mehl da habe ich jetzt
ein Dinkelmehl
jetzt nehme ich zuerst einmal die
Blaubeeren ich nehme da ganz gerne die
aus dem Tiefkühlfach denn die sind auch
im innen blau es ist ja so dass
Blaubeeren früher innen und außen blau
waren und wenn man sie dann gesammelt
hat und gegessen hat hatte man blauer
Finger blaue Lippen deswegen wurden sie
irgendwann kultiviert und gezüchtet
damit sie nur noch außen blau und innen
weiß sind aber wenn ihr die aus dem
Tiefkühlfach holt und da eben nicht dran
steht Kulturheidelbeere dann habt ihr
die mit der richtigen Farbe und die
möchte ich jetzt hier eben zum Backen da
gebe ich jetzt Zucker dazu
einen Schuss Zitronensaft
gar nicht so viel dadurch verstärkt sich
das Pink so ein bisschen
und dann kommt das ganze auf den Herd
und wird schön eingekocht das mache ich
jetzt einfach hier mit dem Walker gleich
hoffen wir mal ist die Farbe schön genug
wird
da
okay
lass dir jetzt Zitrone also immer wenn
ich nur ein bisschen Zitronensaft
brauche muss ich echt sagen der Rest
kommt Demenz trinkt Glas
[Musik]
und dann in die Spülmaschine als
Spülmaschinen Deo
ich meine ihr könnt auch hergehen und
eine fertige blaubeermarmelade nehmen
aber ich finde so kann man halt schon
noch mal den Geschmack mit beeinflussen
und eben bestimmen und jetzt einfach
schön einkochen lassen bis es
dickflüssig ist in der Zwischenzeit kann
ich jetzt hier schon mal die Streusel
zubereiten weil wir alle Streusel sehr
lieben dafür einfach alle Zutaten
in die Rührschüssel geben
bisschen Zimt bisschen Salz und gerade
Salz ist bei Streusel echt wichtig damit
sie überhaupt schmeckt
und dann mit der Butter verkneten und
das macht ihr entweder mit den Händen
mit dem Handrührgerät oder auch gerne
hier mit dem Teig Zerhacker
der zerhackt das ganze nämlich gut ohne
dass da die Streuselmasse eben aufwärmt
[Musik]
schaut mal und dann habt ihr so eine
richtig perfekte Streuselmasse
die Streusel packe ich jetzt in den
Kühlschrank da werden sie wieder schön
kalt damit sie später beim Backen auch
schön knusprig werden und die Masse ist
jetzt auch fertig ja die ist richtig
schön dickflüssig sehe ich vom Herd
runter und kann ihn in der Zwischenzeit
den Rührteig machen für die kackies
ach wir Star Wars irgendwie ich bringe
es halt übers Herz
eine Fruchtfüllung zu machen ohne
tonkawonka ich muss Ton machen das passt
einfach auch zum Zimt
perfekt
dann haben wir den Cookie Boden der ist
damit Vanille die Fruchtfüllung mit
Blaubeer Zitrone Tonka und die Streusel
mit Zimt
wow
das will ich jetzt noch ab dann geht es
schneller
für den Rührteig verwende ich 110 Gramm
weiche Butter 50 Gramm Zucker 120 Gramm
braunen Zucker etwas Salz und
Vanilleextrakt ein Ei das ist zimmerwarm
und 175 Gramm Mehl plus einen Viertel
Teelöffel Backpulver ihr könnt hier aber
natürlich auch einfach backmehl
verwenden und Backpulver weglassen
könnt ihr zuerst die weiche Butter in
die Rührschüssel geben und ihr könnt da
auch ganz gerne im Handrührgerät
arbeiten aber Küchenmaschine ist ein
bisschen einfacher für mich dann Zucker
und braunen Zucker dazu die zwei mische
ich jetzt damit ich so einen
intensiveren Geschmack habe ihr könnt
auch kokosblütenzucker nehmen Salz ist
auch dabei
jetzt etwas Vanilleextrakt und dann so
richtig schön cremig rühren so etwa 5
bis 6 Minuten
[Musik]
erst auf niedriger Stufe und dann ein
bisschen höher schalten
jetzt gebe ich hier das Ei dazu das wird
kurz eingerührt
ich freue mich auf Cookies
wir hatten ewig keine Cookies mehr
noch sein jammern
und jetzt gebt ihr das Mehl mit dem
Backpulver einfach zum Teig und rührt
ihn kurz ein
hoffentlich auch
[Musik]
wenn die Konsistenz dann so ist ist sie
wirklich perfekt
dann nehmt ihr euch einen mittleren
Eisportionierer
stecht hier so Kugeln ab die kommen hier
mit etwas Abstand auf einen mit
Dauerbackfolie belegtes Backblech denn
die gehen jetzt schon noch ordentlich
auf
jetzt nehme ich hier einen Messlöffel
von mir taucht den in Mehl
und Form damit so eine kleine Mulde
in den Cookie Teig denn da kommt die
Marmelade rein
jetzt habe ich mir jetzt gerade eben
überlegt
passt weil der ist so schön flach
ansonsten könnt ihr aber auch was gibt
es noch in der Größe entdecke so ein von
einer Flasche
oder ihr könnt den Stil eines
holzlöffels
den Daumen ihr könnt eigentlich alles
nehmen aber das ist perfekt hallo
[Musik]
dann oben drauf crumbles und in der
Theorie also in meinem Kopf
läuft der Cookie Track so ein bisschen
auseinander und dann verteilt sich alles
schön
ich hoffe es gelingt
schade habe ich ein bisschen zu viel
Streusel muss man noch Streusel backen
und pur essen
lauter jubeln
[Musik]
und so kommen sie jetzt direkt in den
vorgeheizten Backofen 190 Grad
ober-/unterhitze oder 170 Grad Heißluft
dann könnt ihr auch zwei Bleche
gleichzeitig backen ich denke mal
10 Minuten
ich werde nach 8 Minuten schon mal
reinschauen und solange mache ich die
anderen Bleche
[Musik]
meine Kekse sind gebacken und abgekühlt
da ist auch wichtig dass ihr sie
abkühlen Last auf dem Blech damit sie
nicht zerbrechen und jetzt sind sie
wirklich schön kalt was ich jetzt noch
machen werde ich bin zwar kein Fan von
weißer Schokolade eher so der
zartbitter-fan aber hier passt ganz gut
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier schon mal
meine weiße Kuvertüre geschmolzen ich
habe sie auch temperiert das heißt zwei
Drittel über dem warmen Wasserbad
erhitzt dann runter vom Wasserbad noch
mal ein Drittel Kuvertüre dazu und kurz
verrührt und jetzt müssen wir uns einmal
nur noch kurz anwärmen dann sollte sie
perfekt sein
und dann wird sie auch schön fest ohne
zu schmieren und ohne einen
kronenschleim zu bekommen man glänzt es
schön
jetzt schön gucken
und wenn keine Klümpchen mehr drin sind
ja
dann kommt's
[Musik]
hallo
diese Spritzbeutel Minis die sind wie so
ein kleiner Gefrierbeutel man könnte da
oben so ein Clip dran machen
unten so eine kleine Spitze wegschneiden
und jetzt lasse ich das hier so drüber
laufen
[Musik]
und dann gleich vom Blech runter nehmen
dann habt ihr einen schönen Abschluss
[Musik]
abkühlen und hole mir gleich jemanden
dazu der die Kekse probieren darf was
ich noch sagen kann wenn ihr frische
Blaubeeren drauflegt sind die Kekse
natürlich weniger haltbar denn frische
Blaubeeren gehen natürlich kaputt die
Kekse an sich wäre nicht so locker also
locker zwei Wochen abgepackt haltbar wie
eben Kekse so sind oder Plätzchen aber
wenn ihr frische Blaubeeren drauf legt
dann eigentlich nur zwei Tage im
Kühlschrank
aber ihr könnt sie auch kurz vor dem
Verzehr drauflegen oder halt auch
weglassen gell
so dann gucken wir jetzt mal bei Kekse
probieren will
heute möchte Jutta probieren hallo
zurück Jutta wir sind zurück
ja mit dem Drehalltag zurück so Jutta
erzähle Jutta ich habe hier Kekse
gebacken Jutta steht die ganze Zeit
dabei
also Kekse ja die sehen ganz cool aus
gell ja ich finde sie alle lecker sollen
wir uns einfach so einen Teilen vor
allen Dingen kann man die Atoll mit
kinderbagger
immer gern ich auch
damit Frucht und crumble
sehr lecker oh die sind richtig gut
ja noch klein waren mehr ein paar Kekse
gemacht
die sind ja so richtig so
amerikanisch so weich im Innern aber
außen knusprig so richtig TUI Cookie im
Inneren weich und soft
und saftig und außen sind schön knusprig
ja richtig gut
danke schön
die sind richtig gut
ich mache mich gleich Tasse Kaffee dazu
ja ich habe meine gerade noch also
probiert das Rezept gerne mal aus auf
sallys-blog.de gibt es das Rezept dazu
oder in meiner App
und ihr könnt mir mal schreiben
was eure Lieblingskekse sind
ich mag die gerne und
die Brownie Cookies
die sind hammer probiert die unbedingt
mal aus und diese Cookies auch ja
also bis zum nächsten
mal rezeptwünsche wie immer gerne in die
Kommentare tschüss
und die geben wir jetzt weiter zum
fotografieren
[Musik]